pas de sommet à bruxelles moscou pour le
moment la russie a réagi à cette annonce
avec regret et se dit toujours disposé à
dialoguer chez le point avec notre
correspondante à moscou vera gossmann
vladimir poutine a été et reste toujours
intéressé par l'établissement de
relations de travail entre moscou et
bruxelles a déclaré le porte parole du
kremlin dmitri peskov
elle a tout de même souligné que la
russie espérait que le pays européens
qui ont une approche plus équilibrée
continuerons à travailler pour
promouvoir le dialogue entre la russie
et l'union européenne je vous propose
d'écouter
nous le regrettons premium vous savez
qu'en général le président poutine a été
et reste toujours intéressé par
l'établissement de relations de travail
entre moscou et bruxelles et sur le plan
conceptuel la position du président
poutine selon laquelle nous sommes prêts
à avancer dans cette direction dans la
mesure où nos homologues sont prêts à le
faire reste évidemment d'actualité
le vice ministre russe des affaires
étrangères alexandre grouchko a quant à
lui déclaré que l'union européenne s'est
retrouvé otage d'une minorité agressive
à savoir les pays baltes et la pologne
il a également noté que pour dialoguer
il fallait être deux mais que l'union
européenne préférée monologuer écouter
l'union européenne s'est retrouvé otage
d'une minorité agressive qui mène le bal
est otage de décisions prises au
préalable
à l'issue du sommet du 24 juin plusieurs
dirigeants européens ont annoncé que les
conditions nécessaires à l'organisation
d'une rencontre souhaitée par la france
et par l'allemagne n'était pour
l'instant pas réunies